اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من جنوب لبنان اهلا
بكم اكثر من
7700 شهيد بينهم نحو 32 طفل في غزه جيش
الاحتلال كثف قصفه على المناطق الشماليه
والشرقيه من القطاع في حين اعلنت كتائب
القسام اطلاق دفعات صاروخيه على تل ابيب
وضواحيها جيش الاحتلال يقطع الاتصالات
والانترنت عن كامل قطاع غزه ومنظمات
حقوقيه تحذر من ان ذلك يهدد باخفاء فضائع
جماعيه وجرائم حرب من جهته اعلن ايلون
ماسك ان شركه ستارلينك ستزود منظمات
الاغاثه المعترف بها دوليا في غزه بخدمات
الاتصال البيت الابيض يقول انه يؤيد هدنه
انسانيه لاطلاق سراح الرهائن ومصادر
للجزيره تتحدث عن سير المفاوضات بشكل
متسارع لانجاز اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
وعقد صفقه تبادل بوسطه قطريه في وقت اعربت
فيه عائلات الاسرائيليين المحتجزين عن
قلقها من التصعيد وطالبت الاجتماع بالمجلس
الوزاري الاسرائيلي
المصغر الجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن اعتراض
صاروخ ارض جو اطلق من لبنان باتجاه منطقه
الجليل الاعلى ويقصف اطراف بلدات في
الجنوب اللبناني وحزب الله يعلن استهداف
عده مواقع اسرائيليه ويؤكد تدمير قسم من
تجهيزاتها
الفنيه صواريخ ايرانيه تضرب قاعده امريكيه
في حقل العمر شرقيه سوريا بعد قصف امريكي
لقواعد تابعه للحرس الثوري المتحدث باسم
البنتاجون قال للجزيره ان القصف دفاع عن
النفس ولا علاقه له بما يحدث في غزه الى
اللقاء